[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm digging the digs bro i give it an
8.5 8.5 on the lens 8.4 you're gonna
like the way you look i guarantee it i
guarantee you stephen
i'm grateful mark
altering
[Music]
oh that's creepy to me
i'm dreaming about that tonight
you may not like my next candidate
here and dear as she is to you
why does he want layla i wonder i mean i
get it i get why anybody would want
layla i'm just saying what is
consciousness
interesting stuff but really creepy
stuff i wouldn't want that man wanting
my girl i'll tell you that he's
definitely not mr steal your girl but uh
in a different way i guess i don't know
what i'm saying mr steal your girl's
soul yeah
welcome back to new rock stars moon
knight episode 2 confirms what the
boomers have been saying in the
beginning that the hippie
chinese-speaking vegans are going to
steal your kids and kill your kids not
even give them a chance
but what exactly were the circumstances
of konshu's initial possession of mark
spector and why does kanchu want layla
next who did mark kill in that backstory
god damn it
now yes yes we polled god emmett versus
what the fish but god am it won by a
margin of three percentage points in
that survey really just 148 votes so
here's what we're gonna do we're still
gonna kick off every episode by
screaming god damn it and then uh every
question that we go through each episode
we're gonna lead with what the fish so
that way we get the best of both worlds
is it too much to ask for both in the
immortals exactly and then we can also
recycle what the fish for name wore
whenever that comes
exactly
exactly maybe sooner or later with that
atlantis bar we saw last episode who
knows
this is inside marvel it's new
rockstar's weekly marvel reaction show
i'm eric voss my easter egg breakdown of
episode 2 is coming later today but
right now i am reacting to this episode
and answering your biggest questions
with mt mt thoughts on episode two
dude i'm so excited to see the mr knight
suit in live action are you kidding me
like i didn't think we get it so soon
like it was the perfect reveal like like
he he he was like not dressed in it in
the last cut and then it just
immediately cuts to a fast
transformation and i just love that
decision it was just like super sad it's
like here it is
and yeah i love it i loved how it
appeared just on the landing uh i'll say
that like i do miss the personality of
the mr knight just a very competent
detective uh a criminologist sherlock
holmes suave yeah but it seems like the
show is just kind of simplifying it in a
way that we have mark and we have
stephen and each of those have their
super powered forms one you have the
moon knight ceremonial warrior closed
the other one you have what steven
thinks would be a panic suit that he
would put together last minute uh and it
and it works it works i think at the end
of the day they both still have
superpowers right he's still got a
wallop on that jackal was able to bend
the fender get a fender bender on that
car so uh
i mean i i loved this episode i loved
how much deeper we go into the mythology
uh into the philosophy of arthur
harrow's cult and you see these folks
who are living their best lives in some
kind of
unobserved corner of london that we
don't know about but uh watch an animal
planet apparently they're all really
just uh watching animal planet with the
boys that's what we all do on a friday
night they all have their wireless
headphones in they're all synced i mean
that's that's the way i want to live
like i assume the rent is uh it's some
kind of co-op right you just do your
shift in the garden uh you get the
soccer ball from off the roof and uh and
that's your short for the week
uh or it's almost on craigslist yeah uh
maybe you kidnap someone from the other
side of town pretending to be a cop and
you drive them over here that's your job
are these people actually cops and
they're using
or those fake badges i gotta assume
they're fake badges fake identities
right
i don't know i think i think they
are actually cops and like maybe
harold's possessing them i don't know is
the entire london police force under
harrow's control
how far does this go
all the way into the house all the way
to the top even kids got tattoos oh my
god you are worried about scrolls no we
got to worry about these emmett were
worshippers who are everywhere uh i mean
i i heard a story recently of uh of
someone who was talking about a minor
diversion here uh someone was talking
about a previous relationship that they
were in and um the relationship was
having issues so they went to get
couples therapy and uh part of the
reason that the relationship was going
bad is the the guy in the relationship
was like getting on the girlfriend for
what it was actually his wife for what
side of the sidewalk to walk on for like
doing things doing chores a very
specific way and then so as they were
talking to the therapist about this the
therapist suddenly sided with the guy
and said oh you're a follower of the way
and then the wife realized that both the
therapist and her husband were part of a
cult
in that therapy session
and that's one of those terrifying
things to realize that you are the one
person in the room who's not part of the
cult and that everyone's speaking the
same terrifying language
and terminology that you're not aware of
so
that's a pretty good
prospect uh anyway poop my pants
yeah yeah uh but that's part of the way
mt they want you to poop your pants it's
just this is the way
it's the better way to do it waste so
much water by using a toilet what are
you crazy that's what i'm saying
i just go right down the leg um i use
one leg per
per um
per poop and then i just change the
pants you get two poops a day are you
really getting more than twice a day are
you kidding me maybe in the morning
like
yeah only two
yeah yeah
let's talk about this episode uh this is
a wild episode so much happened in this
episode we finally started to get some
answers so this uh episode begins with
stephen thinking everything that
happened in the bathroom was just a
dream but as we uh sometimes wake up the
next morning after we did some horrible
things in the bathroom though the night
realized no it was all too real the
smell lingers the smell
sometimes you just wake up in the
morning passed out from a hard night's
poop and like oh what happened
oh shoot the bathroom's destroyed
um we get this great moment where he
goes back to the museum talks to jb
reviews the security footage and
realizes that man versus beast battle
was really man versus self we got a nice
hound of the baskerville's reference in
there uh and and it's almost like fight
club in a way right like re-watching the
security footage and realized it was
just you there uh pretty terrifying
so he gets fired by the most
understanding hr uh manager ever who
gives him a pamphlet
uh
i felt so awkward during that
conversation i was like he's being too
nice he's going to get fired
well my read of that because you know i
got a conspiracy brain is i think that
hr rep was uh part of the cult right
because he decides not to press charges
so why do the detectives show up if no
one pressed charges i guess for a stolen
item right but like how was anything
reported to be stolen i i think he was
part of it i think it was i think we're
going to see that guy in the background
tilling some tomatoes and in that
community garden
because like that because on the
pamphlet we see like a crescent moon on
there which is kind of weird i'm like
why is that i didn't notice the crescent
moon
it's like a green crescent moon on that
pamphlet i'm like why do you have a
crescent moon and what is this place
what's going on here so that guy i don't
trust him
i don't trust any pamphlet don't give me
a pamphlet
i can't carry this around now with me
it's going to get lost in when my coat
pockets yeah like it's not going to
happen do you have a website like i
don't i don't want to carry this time i
don't want to kill
don't ever take anything that people
hand you on the street just don't don't
they own your soul at that point um
so he gets fired he checks in with uh
crawley i have some interesting thoughts
about crowley i mean i think it's
interesting that he's got this long
golden hair and then i think there might
be a visual connection with konshu
having that long stringy hair that kind
of strings is is is crawly a
manifestation of conscious i don't know
i'm probably reaching right now it's so
interesting i find it interesting there
i think that like him talking to crowley
could be evidence of like him like being
able to make conversations with himself
which is why he's talking to nobody on
the phone
oh for sure for sure that's definitely
connected this guy all of his
relationships are the people who don't
do not talk back to him
but anyway he tracks down mark's storage
locker and i keep an eye out for the
easter egg breakdown birds because there
are some interesting easter eggs in the
hunt for that story but um so he finds a
scarab he finds some a chinese currency
he finds some american bills he finds an
american passport of mark spector mark
lays out the truth uh i'm conscious
avatar we try to dispense conscious
justice we're trying to keep this scarab
away from arthur harrow but stephen
refused to give mark the body and then
kanchu gives us some creepy jump scares
in this uh in this hallway
i loved it so much
so creepy like i've i'm the biggest i
can't do horror stuff but like i love
when i get scared and like it's i just
love when like art can make me feel
something and like that was just very
just yeah i don't like a tall bony being
approaching me in the dark
sorry call me weird i mean
mt's being nice about it but i did sneak
up to empty in the dark one time when i
was
very malnourished when we were doing uh
fitness origins and uh and yeah i'm a
tall bony man and he didn't like that
surprise
don't ever hug people from behind it's
just like a form of um
and that's how we first met and that is
how we first met i said guess who
and he said i have no idea what this is
it's college
didn't go well um but uh i mean the
diegetic lighting of this show just the
light coming from the overhead lamps
from the moon from the street lamps oh
my god uh the lights from uh arthur
harrow's staff it's just so cool what
they're doing with lighting on this
series i don't think it would seem very
cool yet like everything
every shot is deliberate in the show i
love it
for sure uh now uh steven meets uh uh
his wife soon to be divorced wife layla
turns out they were married uh and mark
had been avoiding her not returning her
calls and mark even
steven to just get away from her not
talk to her uh but she realizes he has a
scarab uh and she reveals that it points
to amit's tomb kind of like a compass
but then these two detectives arrive
fitzgerald and kennedy right the jfk's
middle name and last name i just thought
that was a little interesting kind of
like are these even their real names um
but uh they're looking for a stolen
object they find mark's passport and
really they're just looking for a reason
to arrest stephen and then they
interestingly pull up mark's police
record for this massacre at a dick site
in egypt uh a couple dead bodies uh some
more interesting easter eggs on that
screen um but i just thought this was
kind of making his doubt mark for a
second like this guy might not be great
or he might have been framed uh we don't
really know yet and i like that we don't
know yet um but of course these cops are
just members of a cult uh but they're
also uh following harrow uh in addition
to
other
that wasn't even funny that wasn't funny
i i butchered that um but uh anyway hero
gives steven a tour of this delightful
place to live you gotta imagine the rent
there
it's gotta be worth it alone i mean hey
man it's the ultimate um youtuber pad
it's that they're just all youtubers
just uh they're all influencers right
they all got their own tick tocks
they're they're living their best lives
uh
and we see the garden he fills them up
on some lentil soup uh they're they're
watching their nature documentaries but
what do you need in life lentil super
nature documentaries
stephen finally uh combats this [ __ ]
amit philosophy that i'm so glad someone
on this show just finally draws the line
at killing kids i love it when people in
this in the show just completely give
the best counter argument to things and
then harold doesn't even have an answer
to it he goes well you know sometimes
you get an amputated child
she was like a kid is it a diseased limb
are you crazy
uh i i wanted to just cut to some other
people in the room like could one person
just be like
yeah yeah the whole take my let's
[Laughter]
i was saying this from the get-go um
but uh harrow threatens him with the
staff of amit which which is interesting
we got another little tease that you
know amit gave this staff to his first
avatar so this is some kind of gift
that's been passed through the
generations um but then layla shows up
to free mark holding up the scarab like
a kind of conch shell i wasn't clear why
layla showed up was she worried that was
she just that confident
that um mark or or stephen in that
moment could summon the suit why would
she need to go in the room to do that uh
why you know i don't know i just had i
don't know what her game plan was in
that moment i'll just push someone off
the scaffolding and then we'll run out
she just probably wanted to save mark
because she probably had no idea well
she probably had no idea what he was
doing with harrow and like was like all
right we know that arrow's trying to
kill us so i'm just gonna save you
because you seem kind of crazy why would
she need to bring the scarab though if
the scarab is the one macguffin they're
trying to keep away from all these
people couldn't she just go in that room
and say like i have it in my hand and
then it'll be like what and she's like
haha now mark some in the suit like i
don't know why she needs to use that to
get their attention if like she could
just lie and say she knows where it is
you know true um yeah it was just
whatever um but uh
steven uh has some performance anxiety
some hulk flavored performance anxiety
can't summon the best of us
happens to all of us it brings us to our
sponsor no that comes later
um so harrow is able to summon a jackal
from this purple
hell realm uh and uh the jackal chase
him down stephen falls out the window
summons a suit but it's really psycho
colonel sanders the dapper mr night look
from the 2014 comics uh but the identity
still has the super strength uh and
steven manages to get a few good hits in
that jackal but still gets overwhelmed
uh we get a grc easter egg on that bus
there that's fun uh but he gives a
control of the body to mark who summons
the true moon knight warrior ceremonial
suit it looks great uh and then lures
the jackal in this chase across london
this is beautifully shot with the
crescent moon uh and it all just leaves
this jack-o'-lantern he's like i got the
one spire of an outdoor cathedral
steeple that i'm that will just be
perfect to to impale this jackal but you
know it's over
it's closer
to uh
to the east side of london you gotta run
past saint paul's to get to so uh just
follow me trust me um but in all of this
uh all these costume changes the scarab
gets loose harrow finds it kills a
homeless guy to get it uh mark refuses
to give stephen back the body steve is
trapped in a mirror we learned that mark
is really in servitude for conscious for
saving his life and kancho is
threatening to take leila as his next
avatar
and then we end the episode with kanchu
transporting mark and stephen to egypt
to stop harrow in the desert
back in egypt baby in a marvel movie
and uh
not wearing it too much not that work
my man oscar
is the delight of all the senses we'll
just leave it there
but uh
the question i'm having empty is this
order of possession among mark spector
and arthur herrera who's a former avatar
of konchu but now an avatar of amit so
he's doing some uh god swapping in the
mix here
what happened there and uh what's gonna
happen next with layla uh like why is
she a conscious next target and what was
this whole dark origin story for all
these characters in egypt that's what
we're talking about in this episode uh
but to celebrate moon night there is a
new latest obsession shirt and tea and i
are rocking it so cool i love this
design so much i love it so boom of the
moon god and folks gotta be honest with
you this is selling faster than victor's
lentil soup recipe so you gotta move
fast go get yours over at
newrockstarsmerch.com folks it's really
the best way to support what we do here
at new rockstars and when you get the
shirt you will unlock the added option
if you choose to do it to write in a
custom shout out that will appear at the
bottom of these after shows and we have
some popping up here oh
thank you all for buying this shirt and
supporting us kyle says i think stephen
is a spell by consciou to protect mark
and himself from evil so you mean the
whole steven identity could be a spell
by khan shu i like your thinking mark i
like that a lot i'm like a botched spell
because contra doesn't really seem to
like stephen very much these days
i'm sorry i mean kyle kyle i like yours
oh you think but uh yeah i mean again
that's kind of the chicken and the egg
debate there right with steven there
before konshu dropped in my thinking is
that stephen or some other identity that
mark had some form of dissociative
identity disorder before kancha came in
just because conscious said like you
said this wouldn't be a problem so i
don't think this i don't i if kanshu
caused it i don't think he would hold
mark responsible for it just be like you
just have to deal with this um so i
think i i think there might have been
steven there before but i i do think
what we're seeing through steven's point
of view might still be an illusion might
still be being filtered or altered in
some way by this possession um
let's see another comment here vin
vinicius that might be how you say it
says maybe harrow was also judged unfit
by amit and that's why he puts glass in
his shoes
interesting uh like that is his penance
that would be really interesting because
like you know what if like ahmed saved
his life the way that kanchu saves
mark's life in the comics and like this
is his way of like you know showing like
we're like repaying on it it's like you
know what i'm just i deserve to be dead
so i'm just gonna walk in pain and so
like i don't know like but i do like the
idea that he was just unfit he was like
hey you're no good so like you have to
walk a glass in your shoes while you
serve me it's like a
like a really mean god yeah or maybe
he's afraid to face that judgment and
he's just worried he knows that he did
bad stuff so he's trying to balance
those scales every day by by incurring
this kind of punishment because that is
kind of this uh self-flagellation uh
like corporeal punishment on yourself um
is something that like really devout
religious zealots have been known to do
in the real world and it kind of seems
like what arthur harrow's doing with
that broken glass so he's like i am a
sinner i am a sinner i'm a sinner so i'm
going to punish myself so that ahmet
when i face those scales won't judge me
uh negatively he doesn't have to do that
all he has to do is watch morbius
empty spit in the fire
sorry but sorry you kind of deserve that
song don't apologize
mt speak your truth and your truth is
that movie was a type of poop and that's
okay
it's also okay if you liked it we don't
judge you for liking it it's all right
yeah like what you like
it's all right um trevor says do you
think it's possible one or a couple
personalities got dusted by the snap
whilst the host remained
trevor man i love your thinking the idea
that there could be other identities we
know that obviously
steven slash mark the body stayed
because he got that passport during the
blip you got it six months into the blip
so the body state but there could be
other identities in there that just got
dusted and then returned now on the
other side of it and stephen could have
been one of those and that's why
suddenly the d.i.d is affecting him in
the middle of this possession by kanchu
is stephen undusted in his head
uh that would be really interesting i
think that you know it i don't think the
the dusting element is gonna come into
the personalities in his head but it's a
really interesting theory for sure yeah
all right let's dive into the theory
we're talking about in this episode what
was the question mt
so
buddy what the fish did mark do that led
to kanchu possessing him yes uh an
excellent question how did uh the gods
come into all these people's lives to
begin all this madness well uh we got
some interesting lines at the end of the
episode mark tells stephen when i am
done when i have repaid my debt i swear
to you you will never see me or hear
from me again we wouldn't be alive if it
weren't for conscious and my servitude
is the price that i pay and then mark
chad and then conscious chides mark
saying you were nothing more than a
corpse when i found you earlier in the
episode when they arrest him fitzgerald
and kevin fitzgerald and kennedy bring
up mark's criminal record and they say
mark spectre was part of a team of
mercenaries that hid a dick site in
egypt here's what they did to the
archaeologists zip tied and shot in the
back of the head execution style and the
computer screen shows at least four
corpses in the sand by the way the
computer also lists the assigned agent
as nick pepin the show's production
manager and then the final number begins
with 1975 which is the year moon knight
debuted and we're off by night number
32. just lots of easter eggs in this
episode stay tuned good eye buddy
so this sounds a lot like mark spector's
origin in the comics mark after stints
with the marines and the cia he becomes
a mercenary with parenchy decomp or
duchamp who we saw on the uh missed
calls last episode uh and they joined
this other mercenary named raul
buschmann and they're all on a raid on
this archaeological site in egypt
buschmann kills the lead archaeologist
named uh peter alvaroon to find the
pharaoh's tomb
but when they kill him they leave behind
the daughter marlene who later becomes
mark's love interest bushman also
mortally wounds mark and mark
crawls his way to the tomb and collapses
beneath the idol of konchu where his
spirit meets with kanchu's spirit and
kanchu agrees to save mark's life in
exchange for mark's service so if this
is the backstory that they do on the
show that actually might mean layla
could be the daughter of one of those
slain archaeologists maybe she doesn't
know what mark did or how it all went
down really but uh which is kind of a
messed up thing for mark to do to marry
this woman if you were involved in her
father's death
that would be kind of crazy i i get
vibes that layla is might have been
involved with mark like while he was a
mercenary like there were just always
mercenaries together but i think they
knew maybe maybe even her dad was part
of this mercenary group he had a
father-daughter mercenary team that
sounds adorable right that'd be fun i
want to see that prequel so i think the
fact that they showed us frenchie's name
last episode means that we're gonna see
this flashback at some point uh but the
question is i think how arthur harrow
fits into all this because he claims to
have been one of konshu's previous
avatars and while he can't see kanchu he
seems to know what kanchu is saying to
mark as if he's heard it all before but
uh also hera recognized market episode
one as a mercenary there was a past
between them
so was harrow part of this past raid on
the archaeologists back when harrow was
doing conscious bidding uh maybe killing
the archaeologists to keep them from
unearthing amit's tomb that might have
been conscious original mission and then
mark might have felt morally conflicted
about helping harrow gun them down and
soharo might have wounded mark to keep
this all a secret but then in a moment
of weakness harrow could have been
seduced by amit and then khanshu
being forced out needing the human
avatar to fight consu and hero's new
partnership took advantage of this dying
guy mark spector the mark could have
agreed to help kanchu to stop harrow and
ahmet as part of his penance for being
part of the team that ended up
killing leila's father that's my
thinking how this all supposed for one
point hero led this mission to uh you
trying to follow conscious orders to
kill these people who were just you know
unearthing ahmed's tomb
uh and then as that happened ahmed came
in made a better offer
and then uh basically uh harrow took up
this mission um the scarab somehow got
displaced or lost in the sands of time
and then mark is like well i'm dying uh
i need to make a good deal and country's
like well this is my best option
i need someone to stop these too i've
been forced out i need to swap into a
new human
i guess the question remains is why do
you think conscious wants layla is
conscious just using that as leverage to
threaten mark to keep him serving him if
you don't if you if you release from me
i'm gonna jump to your wife does he
really want to do that you think i i
think that
you know he wants mark particularly
because mark has a particular set of
skills like mark is super good at his
job like he is a super good mercenary he
used to be in the army like he has all
this training so i think that his
avatars are only as good as they are
capable of um and well obviously they
are also augmented with you know the
super strength and like healing factor
apparently for as we saw in episode one
um so i think that you know
he would rather have mark but he could
easily take leila because as we see in
episode two leila is more than capable
of handling her own self so he's like
you know what i'd rather have mark but
at the end of the day everyone has
somebody that they love so i can use
somebody that
you love to threaten you to into
servitude if you are not you know
already a loyal follower of me because
he has his own agenda he has things that
he has to do and at the end of the day
kanchu really doesn't care i seem like
he does care about
humanity to the point of like he wants
to protect the weak and like the the
vulnerable at night but at the end of
the day he doesn't really care about our
lives in like our love lives and all
that stuff so i think that this is just
what a country does what he's done
probably throughout the centuries he
just
blackmails people because he views love
as weak yeah but i hear that empty and i
think just presently that is absolutely
conscious motive for threatening mark
and to staying in his servitude 100
but i do think there there may be some
honesty there there like layla may be
the original target perhaps layla's
father if they are adapting that story
of marlene's father being the
archaeologist who was killed like what
if layla is part the reason uh
this archaeologist's team was trying to
unearth amit's tomb
is because like they were serving ahmet
in some other way like amit was reaching
out to certain people like come find me
maybe this scarab
really belonged to her and her family
throughout the centuries and that she
could be part of a lineage that was part
of ahmet's original avatar and this
could be like her family curse uh and
that she just has some kind of uh
certain
important historical ancestry that uh
ties in with with ahmet and that
original avatar uh that like in addition
to this scarab that points to his tomb
that maybe this this staff really
belongs to her family or belonged to her
father
and that it got passed down through the
generations and then after the father
died
harrow claimed it uh harrow took on the
mantle of being ahmed's fist of the the
true uh avatar of ahmed uh and that he
feels that guilt for for trying through
konchu
for getting in the middle of that
unearthing process and that's why he now
punches himself with glass on the feet
is he feels bad
for her delaying ahmed's resurrection
because now he is on its uh most loyal
disciple
so interesting i think there might be
something there with laila i think uh
that she may be
a champion maybe a human vessel that all
these gods are really warring over that
she could be the key to their future i
could definitely see that for sure like
because we as we see from
from like what we can tell from like all
these this this new phase of marvel it
seems like these old relics like are
being passed down throughout history
like we have um the the ten rings with
well yeah
when we have the ten rings and then we
have you know the this alligator
staff that apparently harrow was passed
down from from different avatars we've
missed marvel like miss marvel seems to
find her her bangles in an attic that
seems i don't really we don't really
know the plot of this marvel but like it
seems to be like uh family heirloom so i
think that we're entering this new age
and obviously the ebony blade from the
end of eternals which was passed down
from um dan whitman's family so i think
that we're going to see
the history of all these weird artifacts
these magical artifacts that were
probably have all their roots in africa
because we as we learned from um i
believe is the the museum scene from
black panther um killmonger says that
africa was the birthplace of everything
and so like when that meteor hit wakanda
i think that a lot of weird [ __ ] came
with it a lot of like like items and
like all like stuff that hit earth and
so that spread from africa to different
parts of the world um so that's just my
weird wild theory i love that theory mt
i think it's such an interesting
analysis because i mean that that meteor
hit what was it like 5 million bc that
was long before the eternals arrived to
help the sumerians you know so like that
could have been the origin of uh of
earth's i mean my favorite theory or one
of my favorite theories in the past year
is that like that meteor could have
really been the celestial seed um but it
ended up not being the case but i
thought that could have been cool if
like the vibranium in that meteorite
that formed mount bashanga could have
also been the vessel for the celestial
seed that implanted in the core and that
all of it could have been linked i guess
technically it's not wrong yet but i
honestly feel like that you're like that
is what they were sort of going for
because like i think that the vibranium
was sent to fortify the celestial or to
provide it maybe nourishment because we
see that
the flowers from wakanda can grow weird
like you know
empowering flowers from this meteorite
so like maybe it's just nourishment for
the baby it's like here's your prenatal
vitamins through like i don't know
just to make you big and strong for when
you come out so you can have a vibranium
shell it makes you strong and growing
vibranium flintstones vitamins
all right we got a lot more from this
episode we want to talk about but first
we want to thank some friends who helped
us make this episode starting with our
friends at noon mood
so learning to manage daily stress and
anxious thoughts is something we all
want but many of us don't know where to
even begin managing those things well
new mood is here to guide you to mental
wellness and to give you the tools you
need to tackle stress so that you'll
feel empowered to take on whatever life
throws at you their guided approach
teaches you the power of shifting your
mindset in just a few minutes a day with
the team of dedicated coaches you'll
have a support system helping you on
your journey some staff members at new
rockstars have used new mood and they
mentioned how it's helped them
understand their moods and even sleep
better what they like about new mood is
that the lessons are based on science
and they teach you about your
relationship with stress and anxiety so
equip yourself with the knowledge and
skills to steer yourself to happiness
noom has helped millions of people
through their weight loss program so you
know that they can help you tackle
stress too with new mood taking care of
your mental wellness is empowering all
you need is 10 minutes a day and it's an
app so it is there for you anytime
anywhere worry less and feel happier
sign up for your trial at noon.com
marvel that's n-o-o-m dot com slash
marvel to begin your trial and we also
want to thank upstart for sponsoring
this episode we've all been hit by an
unexpected expense or a bill in times
like that it's normal to not really know
where to turn luckily upstart is here to
help upstart powered personal loans can
help you pay down high interest debt all
online with simple and easy to
understand payment terms upstart has
helped over 1.8 million customers on
their path to financial freedom whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date rather than
looking at your credit score alone
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income your employment and
other information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan check your rate in minutes
for loans between 1000 and 50 000
without impacting your credit score you
can even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
don't wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com marvel that's upstart.com
marvel to check out your rate today
don't forget to use our url to let them
know that we sent you loan amounts will
be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
marvel all right mt i have a question
for you
why the fish can only stephen see the
jackals
hmm
that is the biggest question here
because as we saw from the like from the
beginning of the episode not even tv
footage could pick up the jackal and
like people on the streets of london
cannot see the jackal when he's
literally picking people up and throwing
them around so but i think that
the reason why only stephen and mark can
only see the jackal could probably have
to do and this is just my wild theory
here but like with with with stephen and
mark having chaos energy in their brains
in this this dark energy capable of
seeing dark beings like the jackal
whereas people on earth cannot see them
because they don't have that chaos
energy site and like the reason why i
think this is because mostly because of
thor 2 and thor the dark world is
because you love referencing thor the
dark world thor the dark world
establishes so much it's the first like
real movie that we got in the mcu that
like really dives into the cosmos
because like right after that we got
guarded the galaxy and like that really
dove into that as well so i really do
feel like that movie is really important
but anyway heim's doll when um the dark
elves were were a factor he couldn't see
them he can't see the dark elves where
they live and how they move and i think
that this is sort of having to do with
time doll being a being of light and
being in this asgard-like kingdom
whereas those dark beings of you know
the dark elves had dark you know chaos
ether darkness in them so the reason why
i think that only mark can see them is
because this being is pure darkness and
that like weak and those be like or
people on earth who are beings of like
with light infinity energy cannot see
them because they don't have the sight
but it's pretty sure that wanda would be
able to see that being because she has
that chaos
but that's just my theory but that's an
interesting assessment
i i i'm really curious you know there
are all the other people in that cult
warehouse that uh backed away nervously
when uh when harrow was doing the
chanting to summon the jackal like can
they see the jackal or do they just see
like
nothing they just feel a bunch of wind
and they they see an invisible force
crashing through their home like that's
what i want to know it seems like you're
right only people with that kind of like
possession with that kind of or avatars
of someone whether it's ahmet or kanchu
or kathan maybe in wanda's case can can
see uh these supernatural forces i think
that makes the most sense it would just
be hero and uh and
mark or stephen yeah but i but i also
think that maybe the people who have the
tattoos can see the jackal as well
because i think the tattoos itself could
actually be tied to this chaos magic so
like if you have a tattoo then you
probably because we see that all these
people seem creepily in sync um during
this cafeteria sync like every everybody
seems to like be laughing at the same
time like sort of like a wanda
vision-ass scenario where everybody in
westview was sort of linked up through
wanda so i think that that's what's sort
of happening with arrow where like he's
controlling everyone like these people
are not 100
with it but like he's just if they have
the tattoo he's able to like control
them on and off whenever they want i
didn't think about that mt my my
assumption is that they were all there
consenting the way which is scarier for
the cult mindset is that you're
convinced you know it's not like you're
you're being i mean that's the nature of
brainwashing right is it's not
necessarily a supernatural force that is
like mind controlling you it's
using the art of persuasion
and in praying on people's insecurities
to break down the way they perceive the
world and build it up in this creepy
delusional way that serves your own
interests um so i think the
psychological power of uh of cold
persuasion is a real fear of it it's not
that like someone puts a spell on you
but i yeah now you got me thinking like
that ink is it just the anchor is is
that like an enchanted um death eater
tattoo in some way you know i honestly
think it's linked because you know the
pages of the dark hold right how it's
like this weird black
like it's not ink but like this weird
black substance
his blood is black blood on the pages uh
i think it's that same substance in the
tattoo that is making it able to move
and like act around like it i think it's
just this weird darkness that all these
people are connected to to arthur hero
the chaos wi-fi
interesting thoughts all right another
question how did harrow initially come
across khan shu if hero's telling the
truth that he was conscious from our
avatar now he's omits avatar we talked
about that
what happened in the past and how many
other avatars has kanshu possessed over
the years hmm
well we know of two already we know aang
we know korra we know those two avatars
just kidding um
that's a avatar last air butter joke
oh get out
yeah
[Laughter]
i love that show all right no but that's
a really good question um because we we
don't really know
how long harold was for this this avatar
of conscience for and like how they even
met but i'm i had this feeling that
you're probably on the right track here
like i feel like what you i like your
theory of you know maybe well you said
that like harrow and um
mark were mercenaries together at one
point and then like harrow became the
conscious avatar and then switched to
ahmed right that's what i think
this week i think that next week i
honestly think that that could be the
case i love that theory where like they
were both buddies and then they
completely forgot about each other and
they now that they're on these
completely different paths um serving
god so like i think that
yeah
it might have been a quick servitude
before
mark got it but who knows see i think
there might have been uh when when
harrah was a younger guy
uh he might have maybe he was like a
student of of uh one of these
archaeologists on that dig like he was
his mentor was leading the the
exploration and uh and like
he
kind of you know looked up to worship
the sky but you know maybe start
snooping around his stuff found this old
scarab and got interested or something
like that or uh maybe he had some other
history with khan shu maybe there was
some other konchu related relic that uh
that he stumbled into and uh
you know maybe at one point he made some
mistakes in his life and and i'm talking
he would have been really young we're
talking like before midnight ethan hawk
young like early 90s this would have had
to be a long time ago because we're
talking like there's two steps of his
backstory the more recent one he became
possessed by amit and long before that
he was possessed by khanshu so like how
we're talking there's a multiple layer
bean dip to what's going on in ethan
hawk's brain here unless he's lying
about it which is totally possible again
we're talking about unreliable narrators
here we don't know
how much of this
claimed backstory is going to be
revealed is even valid uh by the end of
this season so this may all just be a
waste of our time but i i think
respect bro speculation uh i i think it
sounds like conscious preys upon people
who want to make a kind of deal with the
devil despite to save their own lives
whereas comet makes deals with people
who want to see judgment
uh um
uprooted from sinners before they can
commit to crime so ideologues versus
desperate people who come begging for
help that's kind of the kind of the
difference between those two gods and
who they who they prey upon another
question we've been talking about a bit
empty how widespread is harrow's cult
the hr manager at the museum we talked
about how many members of the police
force are part of the cult
uh is it
we know there is a like an alpine
village
there was a guy who left his shop
wearing his apron still to help steal
the scarab from mark so that guy was
just like what are they doing outside oh
i'm part of this
i have to go join
the fray
and now we have a whole district of
london are there chapters everywhere can
we join where we are i mean who knows i
mean maybe let's ask like our neighbor
like hey are you part of the uh
yeah what i'm talking about you got the
ink
you got the ikea
[Music]
but uh no i think that this cult might
have might just still be a new cult and
has like certain amounts of influence in
certain parts of the world and i think
that you know because of all this weird
[ __ ] happening post the snap and like
you know post uh tiamat just raising
from
the freaking
ground all these people are gonna want
something to believe in and like want a
more pure earth that isn't like that
doesn't have evil in it because like
they're scared of all this evil
happening through all these mcu movies
so um i think that what might be
happening is that these this cult is
growing and like more people are being
are coming across arthur hero at least
like out of intrigue just like who is
this guy and then maybe through his
magic through his magic cane or however
maybe chaos energy in his body he's just
like possessing people that come to see
him out of curiosity and um i i don't
know that's just my weird theory what do
you think uh i think the um i i totally
get why this extremist view of wanting
to um stop sinners in their tracks
before they do the sin
makes sense in this post-thanos world
and post-damn it world which you can't
forget there's a big dead celestial made
of marble in the
indian ocean in this world and no one is
talking about it anyway
um yeah i think people would be freaked
out it might be like can we do something
about this [ __ ] like right i guess my
question is like
it's pretty uncommon uh for a cult to
gain that much steam without someone
becoming aware of its existence like you
know the reg nishi up in oregon got
pretty far uh but then the local townies
are like who are these people who are
here firing guns on the other side of
the hill
this church of scientology uh it started
as like a kind of a quiet little
movement starting in clearwater florida
in hollywood california and then now
some celebrities get on board with it
and then everyone is making fun of them
like
is this is this cult a secret i just i'm
curious to know if ethan hawks going on
tv uh and right now he just kind of
seems like a you know an eon an elon
musk figure that some people are on
board with and other people like dude
that guy's a cold leader don't listen to
what he's got
a guy owns twitter now he owns it all
i really hate that he like bus who owns
twitter it's really uh they hate that
[ __ ] we're 10 years 10
he but he he owns more of twitter than
any other one human being owns twitter
so
interesting world we're now living in um
i just kind of want to know who else all
right i would love to see if like
someone we know someone from the
avengers if happy hogan is like hey look
i got this new tattoo
i lost my girlfriend i turned to
religion check this out
peter's like she wasn't your girlfriend
when she died he's like no technically
technically we were still
yeah
you guys remember what's the it crowd
yes
i remember that episode where the guys
was declaring that he slept with jed
which after she dies
he's like yeah we were totally boating
and she wanted to love me forever but
she died
she said she wanted to she proposed to
me it's so weird
all right
one final question i gotta ask you this
empty because i know you're gonna have a
hell of an answer from where was harrow
summoning the jackal
a purple glowing realm yeah
florida doesn't see those shades of
purple not until storm clouds are coming
in
um no that is a good question where was
he summoning the jackal i i think i have
this weird feeling
that you know the jackal was probably
being summoned from a much farther
region darker region of the universe
where the celestials haven't even
touched yet like there's no stars just
darkness and so because like i just the
way that the ground melts it reminds me
of um the tesseract scene from the
avengers when um when loki first arrived
if you just look at like i don't know
the ceiling when loki first arrives like
it just looks really melted and weird i
just feel like there's a weird
teleportation wormhole situation that's
going on um where this is like it's like
a mini warehome or the jackal's like all
right i'm here now time to go feast on
i'm some some moon knight so i think
that's like a portal situation but
because he only has a little bit of
amit's power and that he can't fully
bring more beings like the jackal and
maybe i'm it to earth so i think that
you know he has a little portal staff
there but what do you think i like that
the hell mouth opened just in that
square tile and like whatever the grout
was that surrounded that tile is like
portal you're not getting past me it's
just gonna be
the the foot and a half by foot and a
half square tile
and you better hope that that jackal
ain't bigger than that because that's
all you're getting just a fraction just
a fraction of her power you're just
getting one tile hero one tile
but no i think you're right empty this
is some other realm i mean i see the
glowing color purple i immediately think
spider-man no way home and morbius uh
the cracks spell that traverses the
borders between known and unknown
realities i think whatever this i don't
think it's another dimension i think
it's a realm between dimensions
where all these gooey gross monsters
float around bumping into each other um
like uh you know so i i think that's
where it's from all these supernatural
creatures that uh they kind of exist in
an upside down space that uh do not
adhere to a specific alternate reality
but when those realities start bumping
into each other and incursions those
incursions open up the grout between the
realities and they live in the grout the
grout is the purple glow purple glow
equals grout
take anything away from this episode
write that down kids purple glow ground
confirmed
that's right the what were the masons
who build this universe the builders
perhaps designs the builders
sticky grout that sticks the universe
together to be
glowing and purple and filled with
jackals
uh but also all that all those weird
things that strange just sucked in his
body in episode four of what i think
those all come from the same place
uh
we went to some interesting places in
this episode of inside marvel as this
episode of uh
moon night went to some interesting
places and it's only going to get
crazier from here folks so again
the breakdown of this episode the easter
egg breakdown coming out later today
it's got some doozies in it it's gonna
be good it's gonna be good um don't
forget to check out all of our great
merch options again tomb of the moon guy
check out the sheriff guys oh my god
this shirt is amazing i think this is
probably my favorite shirt that we have
so i love the design yeah it's fun it's
fun you got nine little the innie ad
kind of
pants they're coming out it's full
filled with these yeah these things
translate issues and it's something it's
probably like eric is a freaking idiot
eric is overrated eric's always going
through [ __ ] theories don't listen
this idiot still thinks mephisto was in
one division yeah
it's all just hate i guarantee it i
don't have time to translate it
well uh
be sure to follow mt and mastertainment
follow me at eavos subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast
thank you all so much for watching be
sure to subscribe to new rock stars and
uh love you guys see you next week late
again
ladies
you